Breaking this morning, First
Republic Bank has become
the second largest bank failure in U.S.
history.
Regulators have seized the bank,
sold off most of its assets
to JPMorgan Chase
in a rescue deal as America's
banking crisis flares up again.
In a statement
this morning, JPMorgan Chase's
CEO Jamie
Dimon says Our government
invited us and others to step up
and we did.
He didn't know
if this will benefit JPMorgan Chase.
We'll talk a lot more about it.
But look, First
Republic is now the third
major bank to fail. Since March.
The announcement comes just hours before
markets open.
And we're keeping
a close eye on Wall
Street to see how it reacts
when the markets open.
Our business
and politics
correspondent Vanessa
Jurkovich, outside of a first year
public bank here in New York City.
Vanessa, good morning to you.
What is so shocking is that 11 weeks ago,
Jamie Dimon and JP Morgan led the way
for all these big banks
to inject
$30 billion into First Republic
to try to save it.
And even that didn't work.
That's right, Poppy.
And later this morning,
when this four
First Republic
branch behind me
and 83 others around the country open,
it will be under new ownership.
JPMorgan Chase buying First Republic Bank
and a deal overnight
announced this morning by the FDIC.
This was an effort by regulators
to shore up
consumer confidence in the banking system
as part of this deal.
JP Morgan
Chase will assume
all deposits of First Republic Bank.
So when people
go to the bank this morning,
their deposits are safe.
This all started to unfold
several weeks ago
after the failure of SVB
and Signature Bank
But as you mentioned,
there was that big cash
infusion of $30 billion led by JP Morgan.
But things really started
to spiral last week.
After the first quarter earnings call
by First Republic, where they revealed
that deposits
fell by 40% totaling about $100 billion.
That sent stock prices falling
just on Friday.
Shares were trading at about $3, down
from about $122 earlier in March.
We do have a statement
from the Treasury Department
out early this morning
reacting to the news.
I will read that to you.
Here's what they said.
Quote, Treasury is encouraged
that this institution was resolved
with the least loss,
the least
cost to the deposit insurance fund
and in a manner
that protected all depositors
The banking system remains
sound and resilient,
and Americans
should feel confident
in the safety of their deposits
and the ability of the banking system
to fulfill its essential function.
Of providing credit
to businesses and families.
So clearly, this is an effort by the FDIC
and offered by JPMorgan Chase
and an effort by the Treasury Department
to assure customers and consumers that
the banking system
here in the United States
is, in fact, safe Poppy.
Still just stunning to see three big U.S.
bank failures since March.
Vanessa, thank you.
We'll check back in
with you throughout the morning.
And Caitlin and Christine,
I mean,
the truth is
the FDIC
still is going to pay $13 billion here
in terms of of the cost of it.
Well, that's
what they've forecast, actually,
because we don't know
what the ultimate costs will be.
But they've said
it could be about 13 billion.
Christine Romans,
you're obviously our chief
business correspondent.
What do we know about the details
of how all of this happened
and what it looks like,
what they've agreed to?
It was just an amazing weekend.
I got to tell you,
I mean, this is JPMorgan
taking over the assets
and the deposits of this bank.
And then there's going to be a loss
sharing provision
with the FDIC for anything that comes up
that could be problematic
on the bank's books.
So that a little bit of a sweetener
from the FDIC
to make sure that JPMorgan
would come to the table.
We know
there was an auction of this bank.
So over the weekend,
you had all these banks
who were vying
for pieces of First Republic,
but it was maybe PNC,
JP Morgan and others.
By the end of you
know, by the end of last week,
it became pretty clear
that the FDIC was going
to have to step in
and take over this bank.
It was not going to be able
to stand alone.
And I think
if you're waking up this morning
and you're looking at this,
I was just talking with a top House
Republican who deals with all of this,
and he says essentially
this is unfinished work
from as we be weakened from what happened
with Signature Valley Bank.
Well, so Silicon Valley Bank. Yeah.
So let's talk about what happened there,
because you had this bank,
First Republic, lost 41% of its deposits.
$100 billion walked out of the door after
SBB and Signature Bank failed,
because what happened
was that showed that
these banks like First Republic,
they have a lot of uninsured deposits.
People didn't want to be sitting there
with all of their money in the bank.
More than $250,000 in a bank
with uninsured deposits.
And so they walked out the front door
and took their money to other banks.
First Republic catered
to wealthy clients on the coasts.
It was known for its $5 million
jumbo mortgages.
So when you talk about Republicans
in the House, look, nobody's
crying over First Republic Bank,
but you don't want chaos and turmoil
to spread
to the rest of the banking system
as well here.
And do we think
that there's going to be chaos
in the banking system
as a result of this?
So I've been talking
to a lot of people over the weekend,
and they think you've called
this unfinished business
They think that what happened with
all that money,
that was the lifeline
that went six weeks ago
that went into the $30 billion
that bought it
some time, know
calmed down
market fears, it bought it
some time
and allowed the industry
to be able to find a way
to manage this problem.
Will there be more banks?
No one knows for sure.
I mean, three big bank failures in
just a couple of months
is really remarkable.
But for the most part,
most banks are perfectly healthy
and will be able to manage
this interest rate risk.
But can we talk about
the FDIC report here?
Because I'm obsessed with this.
This is an aspect of this, you know,
talking about the root causes of here
and what went down.
The FDIC report
basically said that
because they have
so many staffing shortages,
that led to a part of what
we've been seeing playing out
with these banks.
Yeah, that Fed report on
the collapse of SDB
was really interesting, in part
because the Fed is both the regulator
and the supervisor and basically said
there were all these open
red flags at Silicon Valley Bank
that were not followed up on
and that management didn't understand
what was going on.
But also just poor bank
management and
oversight was not as robust
as it should have been.
When I sat down with JPMorgan CEO
Jamie Dimon just last month,
I asked him about these string
of bank failures. Would there be more?
Here's what he said. Ben
This is not 2008.
Okay. This is much more limited.
There are only a handful of banks
that have this particular problem.
They'll eventually be resolved
one way or another.
And I think
people should take a deep breath
in a week or two.
A lot of these banks
have been reporting earnings.
I think they're probably pretty good.
What we subsequently learned
as we bring in Roger Altman, former
deputy secretary of the treasury
and founder and senior
chairman of Evercore. Roger, thank you.
What we learned
when those bank earnings came in
is how much money fled
from First Republic in the first quarter.
But it's notable
because Jamie Dimon,
who's now leading the bank
that is buying up
most of their assets,
is the one who led the initial attempt
to rescue.
He's the one who picked up
the phone, called the other bank
or said, let's get in here.
Let's try to rescue First Republic.
I wonder why it didn't work.
I think it didn't
work because the deposits kept leaving
First Republic.
What basically happened here
is that after the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank a few weeks ago,
a lot of depositors just simply decided
that they didn't want their money
and Medium-Sized Banks,
and they moved that money
either to the very largest banks
like JP Morgan
or Bank of America
or to money market funds
and First Republic in recent weeks lost
almost all of its deposits.
And what happens is
they had to replace those deposits
with a higher cost
and loans from the Federal Home
Loan Bank Board and from the Fed.
And that crushed their earnings,
that crushed their share price.
And it's snowball downhill.
If you're waking up this morning
and you have your deposits at
first public,
if you have a mortgage to first republic,
if you pay your small business
payroll through First Republic,
what do you need to know?
Your fine your fine.
In fact, I find, in fact,
all depositors
in the United States
today are fine,
apparently up to any ceiling because
the new policy essentially.
Well, the new policy essentially is
first of
all deposits up to 250,000 are
and have for a long time
been guaranteed by the FDIC Second,
if your bank is threatened,
it becomes shaky
that the federal authorities
in recent weeks have made clear
that they will protect all deposits
regardless of size.
So effectively,
if your bank account,
your deposits are fine
because the bank is.
If your bank somehow becomes shaky.
Your deposits are fine
because of federal authorities
will protect them.
Two of the things
we've learned that helped lead
to to this failure of First Republic,
two thirds of their deposits
were uninsured,
that a lot of wealthy
clients, business owners you know,
but if you
talk about paying a payroll,
for example, for a company of 100 people
a week, payroll,
two weeks is going to top
the FDIC insured amount of $250,000.
But they had a lot of uninsured deposits
and they also had a loan to capital ratio
that was way bigger than most 111%,
meaning they had more loaned out
than they had deposits in the bank.
Can you regulate against those things?
What would prevent something like this?
Well, first of all, Poppy,
there's no wrong
with having a lot of business
deposits, right.
Go beyond 250,000 if you're a bank,
you want that, right.
So there's nothing unhealthy,
inherently unhealthy about that.
What really happened
here and also happened
was Silicon Valley Bank
is that in the last year or so,
as interest rates rose very quickly
with the Federal Reserve
trying to fight inflation
and being a little late to that game,
they they
found themselves with a mismatch.
They had taken deposits,
invested them in longer term assets
like federal bonds and mortgages.
And as interest rates rose,
they started to lose money
because the cost ineffective
their liabilities went up
and the returns from their assets didn't.
And they had a mismatch. In this case.
It wasn't quite as bad as Silicon
Valley Bank, but it was unhealthy.
And that's what really brought them down.